co-host of CBS morning's Gail King
president of the European commission
Ursula from their lion
Global citizen Ambassador Hugh Hugh
Jackman
Global citizen European board chair and
humanitarian Sabrina Dory Elba
and Global citizen co-founder and CEO
Hugh Evans
hello fellow human beings it's so good
to see everybody I'm really thrilled to
be here you know when I was coming in
when we were walking in backstage this
is day one panel one we're setting the
tone for the next two days and we've all
made a pack we are not going to be the
boring panel for you today you are
welcome when are you coming in they were
playing Harry Styles song in this world
there's just us you know it's not the
same as it was that's so true in this
world it is just us you know it's not
the same as it was and we don't want it
to be the same as it was and that's why
we're here in addition to all of you
here at the Glass House the lovely Glass
House in New York City we've got a huge
social audience with us today social as
you know is very very important we are
live streaming right now on Facebook
Instagram and Linkedin on Reuters
television the Associated Press and
across Europe Canada and Barbados so
we've got all the basis covered today
Global Citizens all over the world they
are watching we'll be hearing from them
as this day goes on so I'm really really
excited to be here today I am so
inspired it's all of you that's why
you're here why everybody who's joining
us and by Global Citizens admission to
end extreme poverty now so how can we do
that because what we all know is that it
can be done
now I first heard about this years ago
it started it's a simple little group of
people in Hugh and Debbie's living room
and I got an invitation to come here
somebody named Hugh Evans I had no idea
who you haven't who who Hugh Evans was
but I did know Hugh Jackman and his
lovely wife Deborah so I go and we're
sitting in the living room it's just a
very small group of us and this 12 year
old starts talking to us he of course
wasn't 12 but he was he he still has a
baby face he was very young very young
and he's still very young but I was so
smitten with the passion that he said
that day in the living room and I walked
out of that room and I have never felt
the same after listening to the facts
and the figures and his his enthusiasm
was infectious so I think it's important
that we start with you Hugh Evans
because you've brought some very
powerful people together for this event
so what makes Global citizen now
different
well firstly I want to thank you Gail
for hosting today and I also yeah let's
give Gail a round of course she's
absolutely wonderful
and I want to thank all of you for being
with us the time that you're giving to
be part of this makes the absolute world
of difference so Global citizen now is
about driving decisive action to tackle
the world's greatest challenges and I
think there's a couple things that make
the next few days different to anything
out there firstly I think that if you
think about you know other Summits that
happen on the planet like let's call it
Davos the world economic Forum or the
Gea General Assembly they're always
behind closed doors and citizens are
excluded this is the complete opposite
this is an opportunity for citizens to
interact with world leaders with
Business Leaders with Incredible artists
so that all of us can come together to
create lasting change it's about
actually the power of citizens to take
action that is different to anything out
there that's why this has been streamed
all over the world I think secondly it's
about action so what we've decided to
drive is targeted actions for those of
you when you came in through the door
today and you gave your cell phone
number you will receive text messages
throughout the entire two days of
specific actions you can take because
often if I go to a summit I might hear
an inspiring speaker but then a few
weeks later I might have forgotten about
it and then a month later it's a distant
memory because we're going to be driving
last in action we're kicking off
campaigns of the next two days that will
have a profound impact and then finally
and most importantly it's about Mission
and the reason why it's about mission is
that we you're going to hear a lot about
climate change over the next few days
and people might say well what does
climate change got to do with Global
Citizens mission to end extreme poverty
now well absolutely everything because
these are two sides of the same coin
called sustainable development and the
only way that we're going to address the
current deadlock in climate negotiations
that's taking place right now the reason
why cop the last cop didn't succeed and
the next cop won't be a guaranteed
success unless we take action is because
there's a 16 billion dollar funding Gap
that the world's wealthiest Nations
promised to the poorest Nations but they
haven't delivered on that creates a
trust deficit
if you don't have trust you don't make
progress and so over the next two days
we have the right people in the room
with the most extraordinary heads of
state Business Leaders artists leaders
Foundation leaders who can all come
together with a movement of Global
Citizens to create lasting change and
that's what's going to make the next two
days last yeah and I know how much
action means to you even going to those
great concerts and we've all been the
lineup is always extraordinary it's
always people you want to see Harry
Styles I love me some Harry is has been
it has been a global citizen Beyonce you
name the names they've all been there
and but even to go to the concert to you
you always make it clear you have to do
something you can't just say oh I love
so and so I want to go you've got to do
something to gain entry into the room
Madam president you are a co-chair along
with you we heard him talk about action
we heard him talk about accountability
what can you do to make sure that there
is accountability because anybody can
say I want to donate I want to do but
how do we hold people accountable what's
the best way to do that accountability
and delivery
accountability and delivery I think to
deliver on what you have promised
I think this is the Hallmark of
democracies because democracies live and
thrive on trust that people trust that
the the promises and the actions that
are promised are really delivered
and therefore I think it is so important
that's also the difference between
democracy and autocracy because we are
accountable thanks God to a free press
to Global citizen to a vibrant civil
society and of course through the checks
and balances that are out there in the
political field and that's what I am so
amazed about what Global citizen is
concerned because we met at the
beginning of the pandemic and you came
and you said let's organize let's rally
the world and let's organize a pledging
for vaccines
um to fight the pandemic and um it was
at that time 16 billion that we raised
in one evening but what was important
Global Citizens then tracked each and
every single dollar and Euro that they
were not only pledged at that evening
but they were really paid into the
system and that they were delivered and
the second time that we've been working
together was on Ukraine Russia's
horrible war in Ukraine and it was you
who said let's again rally the world and
raise money for the Ukrainian refugees
and it were 8 billion euros that you
raised for Ukrainian refugees
and here I was so amazed because you
could you could just feel that people
understood that the ukrainians are not
only fighting for their independent
there in the integrity and of their
territory and their sovereignty but that
they are fighting for our all of us what
the respect for the international law is
concerned what the respect for the U.N
Charter is concerned and therefore it is
so important that we all support Ukraine
for as long as it takes
and again accountability and delivery to
deliver on the subjects that you have
pledged on or where you have promised
things this is the essence of democracy
and to fight for democracy this is the
most noble task that we can fulfill you
know it's a thing uh you
you were really from the school if you
don't ask you don't get and you have
never ever shied away from asking
both of you the U squared I can say that
about the both of you Sabrina the motto
is where ideas become impact and I know
you've worked really closely with global
citizen campaigns connected to food and
hunger and the climate crisis you know
we're not all just sitting up here
looking pretty we really want to make a
difference and we know that these
conversations and these panels and you
get this message out makes a difference
so what have you seen since you started
working with global citizen I think
finally especially when it comes to
climate you know back in the day
people's eyes would glaze over and then
the more examples you give and the more
educated you become you realize Houston
we have a problem
I think that's absolutely right I think
we aren't just here you know just on a
soapbox lending a nice outfit like girls
because you do look it's like looking
pretty
I'll take it
um but what I learned through the years
with the global Citizen and actually I
met Global citizen doing a field visit I
don't know if you remember who Mick was
there with the international fund for
Agricultural Development who I am now un
Goodwill Ambassador for and proudly for
and they were in the trenches doing the
work
um and it took me a moment to realize
because in my mind at that time you know
Sierra Leone had just come out of the
Ebola pandemic which is where we were
Global citizen kneefad were there
picking up the pieces not knowing
ironically we were about to go into a
global pandemic if somebody had told me
that back then I mean I I don't know
what I would have thought but it's it's
so much more than what happens when
you're in those field visits it's the
follow-up it's the ask like Gail said
and Hugh is not shy to ask none of the
global citizen team are but it really is
that accountability two leaders two
Summits that we go to to the panels that
we are having what is the follow up
behind those panels and I've seen and
I'm so thankful to say have been a part
of firsthand some of those commitments
that have been made you know and there's
been a few along the way and some really
important ones and some I'm really proud
of Canada my own home country stepped up
when the pandemic was happening to help
support a rural stimulus facility when
countries were suffering at the most
because let's be honest like Gail said
people roll their eyes when we're
talking about climate but climate is
such um it's so much bigger than
something that's happening when we get
to one degree or whatever people talk
about it's happening to rural people now
people are waking up not knowing what
the weather is going to be tomorrow
having failed crops I mean these are
real life disasters real life situations
they're on the doorsteps of so many and
it's picking up the pieces and and
finding Solutions in real time that help
people that are going through these
issues in real time climate has exactly
everything to do with gender
I mean women make up the majority of the
informal markets their majority of the
rural populations that we are supporting
climate has to do so much with education
how are you sending your children to
school if you're worried about what
you're going to eat tomorrow it's so
much a bigger conversation than I
initially thought and it's easy to roll
our eyes because it seems like something
that's coming 10 15 years down the road
but the work that we do now helps
support the people who have been
forgotten along the way and those are
people in rural communities who are
suffering through climate change today
not tomorrow so I'm so thankful for the
work that we've done together and the
commitments that we've made and it
really is it's a blessing to be a part
of but the work is important in the
follow-up and the follow-up is something
I think that you've done a really good
job highly yes I mean Sabrina would if
you don't have the planet what do you
have you know and I think people really
need to understand how dire this is do
you have something do you have just a
little climate nugget I'll uh I call it
for lack of a better word that the first
time you heard this statistic or you
heard this philosophy you said oh
we better pay it was did you ever have a
holy moment about something about
climate that sort of Jarred you into
reality there's so many holy s moments
um but to be honest hearing that you
know the people who we support through
efad who are rural people around the
world in the agricultural sector feed a
third
of the world's Planet one third
that how are we forgetting about people
who feed a third of our planet and how
are they going to do that if we don't
help support them fight climate change
and protect them when Nature is
literally knocking on their door and
it was astonishing to me the lack of
funding the lack of awareness and
because these people look like me and
you Gail these are black and brown
people around the world rural people who
have not
had an opportunity to express the pain
and you know when we do these visits and
and I get an opportunity to meet some of
these people I just think oh gosh like
these are the voices we should be
championing and Global citizen if
anything has done that has had an
amazing way of highlighting voices that
have not been heard who don't make new
segments
um and and that's something that I'm
really proud of yes yes yes Hugh Jackman
I I can't stress enough
um the impact that night in your your
apartment that day listening to Hugh
Evans speak and I know that since then
you've been involved from the very very
beginning and you've and you've really
encouraged other people to get involved
I would imagine that Hugh calls you at
all hours of the day and night back in
the day was there ever a time when your
caller ID said Hugh Evans and you said
not here
but that you didn't pick up the phone
because you're thinking oh Hugh Evans is
calling again
and I'm only I'm only kidding about he
was sleeping on my couch
it's true is that true yeah so there was
no getting away from him
I'm just coming up I've got a meeting
and I'm like he would say night days
I didn't realize we haven't told that
story before but that is true I have
another very important statistic because
I was there not very long ago in Turks
and Caicos at Hugh Evans 40th birthday
so he's no longer a child I just want to
be very clear yes this baby face is
actually a grown up yeah don't be fooled
by the baby face um
Relentless go ahead he was what he's
Relentless he really is but Relentless
in a good way yes sometimes people are
Relentless and it's extremely annoying
where they're capital A this is not what
this man does and I can't stress that
enough I encourage all of you to figure
out a way to have a conversation with
him if you haven't already but Hugh
Jackman since you've been here from the
very start what changes and results have
you seen over the years oh so many
changes I mean the
it was 2008 when we first met and I was
so impressed by Hugh as as a man as a
young man his vision he was clear he was
a disrupter but before people even
thought about disruptors right was that
yes but will it sustain and will there
be trust built as you said Madam
president and that is what has been so
extraordinary I think by Hughes
leadership and the entire team of global
Citizen and now here we are uh 10 10
concerts now in Central Park there's
been 33 million actions taken by Global
Citizens there's been 43 billion dollars
raised uh because of those actions and
1.3 billion lives affected that's a lot
from one organization and this started
as an idea 14 15 years ago but what has
been extraordinary is how it's just
grown year in year out and we saw
incredible work as you said with Ukraine
with covert we continue to see great
work and I know it's going to keep
growing because this is a movement it's
like it started as a very bright light I
was like this is an amazing idea it is
now a wildfire and it is just scorching
through and it's really at a Tipping
Point now where I feel it could become
really one of the major forces for Real
Change it's did it started out as a
little bright light and now it is a
wildfire and can I say this guys none of
us want to get burned Sabrina what
specific actions do you think that
citizens and government leaders can
address can take to address the root of
food insecurity
you know and just to the point again
that he was making about how Global
hunger and climate are an Inseparable
conversation now it's for me it's
adaptation adaptation adaptation it's
about protecting and creating ways for
Rural people to protect themselves
against the effects of climate change
and you know countries really are now I
think after many of bilat with you and
Mick starting to understand that
long-term thinking is what we need to
switch to you know there's a lot of
short-term Solutions when you see a
famine these things are important Aid is
important but what are we doing to keep
these uh these instances from happening
again for instance you know I'm I'm
Somali and I don't know if you're aware
what's happening in Somalia right now
but there is another famine another
famine this it doesn't have to be this
way I mean we need to set in stone
measures to build resilience for Rural
people so that when these things do
happen we're not hearing the f word
again and again I've heard it my whole
life now and I'm sick of it so just to
be able to you know pick up with
governments and you know actually even
Germany stepped up and cleared arrears
for Somalia when it came to efat so that
we could unlock 30 million uh in new
funding to be able to to spend towards
adaptation I just it's it's one percent
of the funding at the moment and it
needs to be at least 50 when you're
talking adaptation and mitigation
um so I'm looking forward to picking up
on those conversations and then on a
individual level and one of the reasons
I think panels like this are so
important it's about listening learning
and using your voice because everybody
in this room now has learned something
from one of the panelists up here that
they can now share or help spread the
information for my mom always said to me
you know your voice is the most
important thing you have because even if
you can speak to one person you are
influencing some kind of change and it
is so important to remember that Global
citizen provides everything you need to
be able to use your voice in a way that
actually matters and that's all they're
asking if you don't have a dollar to
your name your voice is worth more so I
think it's so important to remember that
I also think that for those people who
have the power of the microphone please
use it for good because there will come
a time when you will no longer have the
microphone and could we just say
congratulations and happy anniversary to
Sabrina she and her lovely husband Idris
Elba have been just celebrated an
anniversary here in New York City and
now she's with you happy anniversary
happy anniversary thank you
um you Jackman you said that
sustainability is something I've seen
this in action with you that you've been
very passionate about your whole life so
can you share with the audience how you
took that passion that you have and you
turned it into to action I went to
Ethiopia 2009 as an ambassador for World
Vision and we did some work with fair
trade Farmers I met a guy called ducali
he had uh five children as sixth on the
way and I spent a day working with him
in his farm and he didn't speak a word
of English and somehow by the end we
became friend
working with somebody and their farm and
they don't speak English and you don't
speak their language how did you
communicate that way he just pointed
dude like gave me the shovel do this
okay I just followed got it got it and
it was the hottest work I've ever done
I'm an actor after all this is I'm like
golly I can do this for like 30 minutes
that's it
um but I made a promise to him that I
would do whatever I could to help
farmers like him fair trade farmers and
so uh in New York City here me and my
partner started a non-for-profit Cafe
Laughing Man coffee which is down on
Dwayne Street if you want to go and get
it we give our profits back to the
farmers we buy from like to Carly could
you say the name of that again please
you laughing or laughing laughing man
Cafe okay there's two of them a third on
the way but it's it was just a small way
for us to uh to connect the dots and to
how I could use my platform hopefully to
to make a difference to the people we
met you know because I think as Sabrina
was saying there's so many small farmers
like ducali who are on the edge One Bad
season it's all over you know the
instability and the insecurity they live
with is just unimaginable to most of us
here and a little bit of help from us
goes such a massive massive way and I
always go back my dad used to remind me
you know what Mandela always said it's
poverty is not natural it's not a normal
state of me it may be around but it is
human made and it can be human corrected
as well it's up to all of us there's
more than enough resources for everyone
on this planet we just have to find
creative ways to share them yes poverty
is not natural I love their plan
do I know who Evans you've never backed
down from a challenge and so I want to
end with Madam president but before we
do that what's the first step you think
we can all take to make an impact
well I think firstly it's important to
realize that in this room are some
absolutely Extraordinary People I'm
going to single a few people out
Michelle Anthony and Kelly Curtis at the
front are two of the most important
leaders in the music industry in the
United States prime minister Ernest
Solberg of Norway who ran the entire
Norwegian economy for the last 10 years
and has now joined the global citizen
board Richard Curtis at the back there
who's probably the greatest filmmaker of
our entire time and is also the champion
of the sustainable development goals in
this room are the people you can work
with to drive campaigns that can create
lasting change and on the topic of prime
minister Solberg I want to share with
you one example that shows the power of
citizen action a few years ago with
Stephen Colbert when prime minister when
Solberg was still prime minister we
launched what we called the Twitter
invasion of Norway for girls education
and one night on Stephen Colbert's show
together with Global Citizens we sent so
many tweets to prime minister Solberg
that she called us for from Oslo the
next day and said come to Oslo I'm sick
and tired of seeing all your tweets I'm
in the middle of a local election and I
need you to shut up and um true story
and so we flew to us I'm not joking this
is actually what happened we flew to
Oslo the next day and she said what do
you want in a bit nicer way than that
and um and and two weeks later two
months later beg your pardon she got up
on stage at Global Citizen and committed
200 million dollars for girls education
so that's the power of
[Music]
um
and and I say that I say that because
the next few days
you're about to hear in addition to what
you've already heard you're about to
hear from people who have plans to
create lasting change
Mia Motley the Prime Minister of
Barbados who's with us right now
has been one of the few people who've
championed the issue of fair financing
for the emerging markets and for the
developing world
most of the world's poor don't live in
the poorest economies they live in the
middle income countries so you actually
have to address this as an issue of fair
financing globally now the thing that
we're going to do as part of the next
few days is we're going to make it easy
to take action but it only starts there
it doesn't end there and what I mean by
that is that if you I don't know if any
of you are golfers in the room if you
play golf but we're you know we're not
going to ask you to hit a hole in one on
a par four
we're going to put it right up to the
on on the
thanks t-box you're a legend
thank you and we're going to help make
it easy to get that Putt in right and
that's just the beginning that's the
example of that campaign with prime
minister Solberg but I want you to all
design campaigns because no one has a
monopoly over good ideas and we need the
ideas of young entrepreneurs from all
around the world who want to design the
next campaigns from Global citizen who
are going to take over my role who are
going to take over mixed role are going
to take over all of our roles because
it's not about us the mission is always
greater than all of us and that's what
we're fighting for yes yes yes thank you
Hugh Madam president I want to close
this session with you because this
number is pretty staggering to me listen
to this guys wealthy Nations promise to
mobilize 100 billion dollars annually to
help developing countries who are
disproportionately impacted by climate
change but they are 16 billion dollars
short that's a very big gap
what do you think can be done to make
sure they step up and honor their
promise we've talked in the beginning
about trust deficit yes you're right
this is a big gap and it is shameful
that when it have not been able in the
last years to fill that Gap the European
Union has stepped up we have contributed
23 billion to the 100 billion but the 16
billion are still missing
so we have to Rally my peers that we
come up with the 16 billion this year
because I just said it it's a question
of trust and disappointment and we
cannot disappoint those who are
benefiting from the 100 billion dollars
so you have my word that I will do
everything this year to find you know
those who have not delivered so far and
discuss stuff with them that should we
shame them
well send text messages this is good and
tweets and as much as you can yes
um as much as you can nudge them towards
that and of course it's my job also to
to Rally my peers and to say listen we
have to fill this 16 billion but we also
can do more than that it's not 100
billion only you said it Sabrina that it
is the action that counts that has to be
done now and I think the highly
developed country first of all have to
deliver themselves we are the polluters
so um this was for me the most important
part when I started my mandate to have a
very clear political Vision this is the
European green deal we have cast our our
goals in a law because I think only what
gets measured gets done so I'm a big fan
of goals that you can then follow up
whether they are being delivered and we
have by now put a price on carbon not
only in industry but we're just
finalizing the law to put a price on
carbon in Road Transport in buildings in
Maritime in aviation because a price on
carbon means very simply if you want to
pollute you have to pay heavily if you
don't want to pay well then innovate and
go into Renewables for example go into
clean Technologies and this is the way
out and it works it works but it's not
only the work at home
it's also the work abroad and there I we
have started a program that we call
global gateway where we invest together
with countries for example from the
global South
because
if we speak about fighting climate
change we speak about clean energy we
speak about wind we speak about solar
it's green hydrogen and these resources
are in abundance in the global South so
it's in our common interest that we
invest for example in green hydrogen
that is being produced for example in
Africa and used in Africa but for them
also a source of income by having the
European Union as
um as somebody who says we are willing
of course to take the green hydrogen
that you want to export or for example
invest in the Great Basin to prevent
deforestation invest in Electric
Mobility
in for example Bangladesh or Costa Rica
so all these are projects We are
following up and I want to say today
because it's not only action over time
but it's action now that as your
European Union we have decided together
with the European Investment Bank that
we will mobilize another 18 billion
euros to make sure that there is
investment in critical infrastructure
infrastructure in the global South to
fight climate change together it's
action now that counts all right Madam
president
you have had the last word you've had
the last word thank you so much over the
next two days guys you're going to be
hearing from artists world leaders
private sector and Global Citizens from
all around the world on this planet
we're going to find out what action
every one of us can take to address the
most critical issues that are facing the
world this is the place where ideas
become impact people thank you for your
time thank you
[Applause]